MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Maya Kaczorowski.
I'm a product
manager in security.
And today we'll be talking
about container security.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
So we'll cover a couple
different topics today.
First we'll start with, kind
of, container security 101.
Why are containers different
to secure than VMs are?
Then we'll talk about the
secure software supply
chain and deep dive into two
of our newest products, Google
Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanning
and binary authorization.
Lastly, we'll see what else you
should be doing in this space,
beyond software supply chain.
How else can you
protect your containers
running in production?
So starting off with
container security 101.
A lot of what's needed
to protect containers
are constructs that we're
already familiar with.
They're similar to
things we have VMs.
We still want firewalls, access
management, audit logging, IDS,
IPS, and more.
The concepts that you need
for securing your containers
aren't dramatically different.
But the mindset of constantly
rebuilding and redeploying
containers is what's changed.
So what specifically
is different?
Let's get that out of the way
first in terms of how security
is implemented for containers.
First is the surface of attack.
A container bundles
binaries and libraries
as part of the container image.
So you don't need as
much in the host image.
If you're using
containers as intended,
that host OS doesn't
have as much bloat, which
reduces the surface of attack.
Next, resource isolation--
this is built into containers,
allowing you to easily
allocate resources,
like storage volumes, to certain
processes using namespaces.
In terms of
provisioning, containers
have normal access
controls like you'd
expect for controlling
access to shared resources
and restricting
apps' privileges.
That being said, containers by
construction are more powerful
and have a wider
range of sys calls
that they can form the kernel.
And lastly,
lifetime-- containers
are meant to be immutable and
are frequently redeployed.
So they're fairly short lived.
In fact, 95% of containers
live less than a week.
This should make it
harder for an attacker
to persist in your environment.
But it also means that
if something does go bad,
by the time that you realize
it, the effective container
might not be there
anymore, and you
won't be able to do forensics.
So what kinds of threats
are there to containers?
What are we seeing in the wild?
How do we categorize
these threats?
First is the set of threats
to container peripherals,
like credential compromise
and privilege escalation.
This is about how to get the
Kubernetes API to do something
that you might
not want it to do.
Next is what ends up running
in your infrastructure.
You might be pulling images
from public repositories
or have dependencies on
unsupported open source code.
If there's a new zero day
vulnerability discovered
tomorrow, how do you figure
out if you're affected,
and how do you quickly
patch yourself?
And there are things that we
hear people get really scared
about, things like DOS attacks
and flooding your event
pipeline, or even
container escapes.
And this is how we're thinking
about container security
at Google.
If you think about
what kinds of controls
we can put in place for each
of these types of threats,
we end up with
three main pillars--
how you develop your
applications, how you make sure
your images are good
to build and deploy,
and how you protect
your containers
while they're running.
So the first one there,
infrastructure security,
is about ensuring that
your developers have
the tools that they
need to securely build
containerized services.
This includes identity and
access management, logging,
secret management,
networking, other such tools.
The software supply
chain is about ensuring
that you know
exactly what's being
deployed in your environment
and that it belongs there.
This is about securing the
host image, the container
image, and the
application code itself.
Lastly, runtime security
is about ensuring
that your security response
team can detect and respond
to security threats
to containers
running in your environment.
So today we're going to focus
on that middle piece here,
the secured software
supply chain.
So even if how you secure
containers is actually
very similar to VMs, except
for some of the differences
that we pointed out, running
containerized microservices
leads to a different
security model.
You have a fundamentally
different mindset to adopt,
which arguably actually leads
to better security longer term.
First off, containers are
meant to be short lived
and frequently redeployed.
Rather than pushing a
single line of code change,
rebuild and redeploy
the whole image.
If you have other processes
that can take place passively,
like patching your
OS for example,
you can be constantly
doing these.
You don't have to have any
Sunday 2:00 AM maintenance
windows.
Containers are also
meant to be immutable.
This is related to
the previous point.
So you're not changing
single lines of code.
You're changing
whole containers.
What that means is that you
have a single chokepoint
for everything
that gets deployed
into your infrastructure.
If you're deploying frequently,
you can actually really
quickly see and
control what's being
run in your infrastructure.
A common concern
about containers
is they don't provide a strong
way to contain workloads,
or rather, VMs have
a strong boundary,
like a hypervisor,
that's well understood.
As a result, users are
hesitant about running
multi-tenant environments,
that is deploying
two containers for different
workloads on the same VM
because they're worried about
one workload affecting another.
This is a fair concern
but no longer really true
with containers.
We now have technologies like
gVisor that are specifically
built to remediate this risk.
So the primary counter
argument for containers
is actually now one of
its greatest strengths.
And lastly, containers and
orchestration platforms
like Kubernetes have
security features built in.
A lot of security changes, when
they're not already enabled,
are simple config changes.
You don't need to go
build a new tool yourself
in order to
[INAUDIBLE] something.
So altogether it
means that, yes,
that your mental
model is different.
But if you actually have much
stronger security properties.
So as we talk about the secure
software supply chain today,
we're really focusing
on the first two pieces.
Let's look at those
a bit more deeply.
The fact that we have
short-lived, frequently
redeployed containers, and that
they're meant to be immutable,
together this dictates
a lot of what goes on
in your software supply chain.
How is this actually different?
Well, historically, a monolithic
application running on a VM,
to make a change,
your developers
would need to SSH
into that machine
or push code changes without
necessarily predicting
the impact that would have on
the rest of your environment,
what you see on the left there.
There are manual adjustments,
including for maintenance
operations, like restarts.
With containers, you
can have a pipeline.
You can push code to images,
which then go through
your design requirements
for build, test, scan,
et cetera, until deployment.
Micro services are redeployed
as individual container images
rather than changing
specific lines of code.
It's easier to debug, and
it's easier to change.
And so from your code, you
might create a base image that
goes through your pipeline.
What we're going
to focus on today
are two items that
you can integrate
into your pipeline between
developing your code
and pushing into production.
The first is Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanning.
You might want to store a
certain image metadata as part
of your image repository,
including, notably,
whether your images have
known vulnerabilities.
And the second one is
binary authorization.
You might want to enforce
that your images meet
certain requirements before you
deploy them to your production
environment.
So let's dig into this.
First up, Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanning.
JUAN SEBASTIAN OVIEDO:
Thank you, Maya.
Hello, everyone.
I'm going to talk [INAUDIBLE]
Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanning.
Essentially what Container
Registry Vulnerability Scanning
does is it scans your images
in Google Container Registry
for known vulnerabilities
by checking
the corresponding
security databases.
The value in this
is that enables
you to identify vulnerabilities
before deployment.
So you can address
them and in that way
protect your application
and protect your customers
and your infrastructure.
Currently, the product
supports Debian, Ubuntu,
and Alpine-based images
by reactively working
on any support
[INAUDIBLE] distributions,
like CentOS and Red Hat.
What it does is once
vulnerabilities are found,
alerts are generated using
our Pub/Sub integration.
And they also surface in our
UI, our CLI, and also VR APIs.
Images are scanned as soon
as you push them into GCR.
And also, after
that initial scan,
we continuously analyze them.
And as new vulnerabilities
are discovered,
we surface that
information for you.
So once you find a vulnerability
using Vulnerability Scanner,
how should you react?
What should you do?
Well, as I mentioned,
the information
is made easily available
for you via the UI, the CLI,
and the API.
You can also use something
like the GCP mobile application
to set up push notifications
so you're alerted when
your vulnerabilities are found.
Also, with Pub/Sub,
this gives you
a lot of power in terms
of plug in the findings
and plug in the
vulnerability information
into other parts
of your workflow.
And you can use some Cloud
Functions to essentially enable
a communication between
these different systems.
An example could be using
the Pub/Sub notification
information via Cloud
Functions to then generate
an issue or an item
to track in your repo
so that someone is assigned
to that vulnerability,
and it can be further
analyzed and addressed.
In terms of how to
mitigate vulnerabilities
and how to prevent them
in the first place,
there are three
general categories.
The first category is basically
updating your packages.
So this is easier
said than done.
But it's very important
for you to regularly update
the components that you use
to build your images as part
of your Docker build images
and your general build process,
something as simple as getUpdate
and getUpgrade goes a long way
during that.
All components are updated,
and you're not exposed
to previous vulnerabilities.
Category number two
is removing packages.
Essentially, if you
use a stock base image
from Ubuntu or Debian, those
come in with a large set
of packages.
And many times your application
wouldn't need all of those
to run.
So it's important for you
to analyze and understand
what packages do I
really need and then
to remove the ones
that are not necessary.
And then the third category
is using a new distribution.
For example, Alpine
and Debian Slim
are much lighter
and much smaller.
And by using one
of those, if you're
able to run your
application on those,
the attack surface is
significantly reduced,
and your software
supply chain can
be secure much more effectively
by using one of those.
So in terms of Container
Registry Vulnerability
Scanning, to use it, we're
currently in our first unit
to join the Container
Analysis Google Group.
This is going to change
soon, once we go to beta.
But basically what you'll do
is you need to enable the API.
And after you do that, you'll
start to see information,
like basically your
images will be scanned.
You'll see a status
change to scanning.
And once the process
is completed,
you'll be able to
look over the results
and find the number of
vulnerabilities in a given
image, like in the
image in the slide.
In terms of some basically key
definitions for vulnerability
scanning, a note is a detailed
description of a vulnerability.
So for example, the severity
of it, the severity score,
and occurrence is
information as to where
it happened, where
it was found, so
for example, what
package it applies to.
And a vulnerability
result is the summary
of the different
vulnerabilities that
were found in a corresponding
image, basically the summary
result that you see in
the middle of the screen
there in the slide.
So I'm going to give
you a quick demo
of the vulnerability scanning
UI and walk you through it.
So here we're starting
from the console.
And then what I'll
do here is I'll
search for Container Registry.
Once I go there, I'll be able to
see all of the different images
that I've pushed.
So as you can see here, I have
different categories of images.
I'm going through the
Python-based images.
And in there you'll see that
I've pushed three images.
The bottom one, you
start Debian as the base.
And as you can see
in the summary,
there are five vulnerabilities
where fixes were found,
and a total of 509
vulnerabilities were found.
In the Summary page, you
can see this scan results
at the top, which give you the
counts for the total, the ones
that have fixes available.
That accounts for
different severities.
And then you can
scroll down the list.
And in each row you can find
the severity, the score,
whether a fix is
available or not,
the package that it
applies to, and also
a link to the documentation
where you can learn more
about the vulnerability.
Something also you
can do is you can
scroll through the
different pages
to find all of the information.
And you can also sort by column.
So for example, in this case, I
sorted for the vulnerabilities
that have fixes available.
And then when you click in
a specific vulnerability,
you'll be able to
see details about it.
So for example,
you'll see when it
was created, when it
was updated, details,
how the occurrence, the note.
And importantly,
you also see links
to documentation for the
specific vulnerabilities.
So you learn what remediation
steps you can take.
Now, going back, the
second image that I pushed,
you start Debian Slim base.
So as you can see, this one
has fewer vulnerabilities,
51 in total, and none
of them with fixes.
And as I showed you before, when
I go through the list of items,
I can see the overall counts,
rows for each vulnerability.
And clicking on each
of them gives me
more details in terms
of what I should
do by going to the vulnerability
documentation page.
And then the last image that
I pushed was based on Alpine.
And as I mentioned, Alpine is
a much smaller distribution,
much lighter.
So in this case, no known
vulnerabilities were found.
So what you can see here
is, as you go through it,
basically when you push
images, they are analyzed.
The information is
made available for you.
And very importantly, you are
given information on actions
that you could take by
going into that Details page
on potentially how you can
address a vulnerability.
Something else that I
want to cover is Grafeas.
Grafeas is an open
artifact metadata API
that we've worked on
with the community.
What it does is it enables
you to have a consistent way
to store information
about the artifacts
and the general items
in your build process
so that you can reason about it.
Essentially, you can know
what artifacts you have,
whether or not they
have vulnerabilities.
You can sort that information.
And then you can
also know what's
running in production, what's
in different environments
and based on that information
make informed decisions
to protect your supply chain.
As I mentioned, this is
something that is open.
So you can add new metadata
types and providers
as your supply chain
evolves and grows.
It's an open standard that we've
worked on with contributors,
like JFrog, Red Hat, IBM, Black
Duck, Twistlock, Aqua Security,
CoreOS, among others.
It gives you full visibility
into the artifacts
that are going through your
supply chain and their state
and different metadata.
And you can set up an
instance to run on premises.
But then also, our
Container Analysis API
for Vulnerability Scanner
is an implementation
of the Grafeas open API.
And you can learn more about it
by going to Kelsey Hightower's
tutorial on GitHub.
You can learn how to set up your
own instance and how to run it.
And now Sandra's going to talk
about binary authorization.
SANDRA GUO: Hello.
My name is Sandra.
I'm here to talk about
binary authorization.
So as Maya mentioned earlier,
that containers give you
a way to apply
consistent changes
and avoid on-demand direct
manipulation of running
production jobs.
So in the container model,
developers no longer directly
patch updates,
restart running jobs.
Instead, organizations
can have a consistent way
to apply changes to any
production workload,
be it modifications
or new deployment.
A lot of organizations have
implemented streamlined tests
as part of their CI/CD pipelines
to apply security, as well
as integrity tests to make
sure that the changes made
in production meets
their requirement.
However, this approach still
does not change the fact
that deployment controls
is identity based, i.e.,
restricting who can
deploy, not restricting
what can be deployed.
So in this setup,
organizations are still
vulnerable to deployment
of untrusted code.
A developer could
still potentially build
a container outside
of the secure
build environment and deploy
it on production environment.
As long as the developer
has permission to deploy,
this untrusted code will
still go through and affect
running production jobs.
And that's where binary
authorization comes in.
Binary authorization is a
deploy time policy enforcement
that uses signature
verification to allow
you to define what
can be deployed,
in addition to restricting
who can deploy code.
It integrates with the
GKE Deployment API.
And it supports both signature
verification, as well as
image whitelisting to
support various use cases,
such as making sure
that images are
built by trusted CI/CD pipeline
before getting deployed
in production environment,
or only deploy images
that pass certain
security or quality tests,
or only deploy explicitly
authorized third-party images.
Let's take a look
at how it works.
Binary authorization
works by integrating
with certain CI/CD stages and
record a signature, or what
we call attestation, as
the image passes through
with the particular
CI/CD stage successfully.
So in this example, the builder
would issue an attestation
signifying that the image
was built successfully
by the trusted builder.
Similarity, tests
would sign, or attest
the image, if the image
passes necessary tests,
as well as
vulnerability scanning.
If the image has passed
necessary vulnerability
scanning checks,
the scanner would
issue another attestation.
As the time the image
comes to deployment,
there are a set of evidences
that's already accumulated
for the image that customers
can use to define policies
and codify what requirement
must the image meet
before it can enter the
production environment.
In this model, an
authorized developer
can try to deploy something
that does not have
the necessary attestations.
But this would fail,
and an annotation
would be added in the audit
log for this deployment attempt
so that security team can
review this incident later on.
We understand that
organizations don't just
want in-house built softwares.
A lot of the existing
vulnerabilities
are found in
third-party software.
Binary authorization
supports this
by giving organization
security teams a tool
to define white list of what
third-party images are allowed
in their production environment
so that they can have
centralized control
over the software,
as well as different versions
of the software deployed
on the organization's
infrastructure.
So in this example,
the security team
would define white
list, only allowing
a particular version of Nginx
that they deem as secure.
So when a developer deploys
this allowed version of Nginx,
the deployment goes
through because it
is allowed by the white list.
But if a developer, either
malicious or accidentally
deploy something
that is outdated,
not allowed by the security
team, the deployment will fail.
Again, an annotation would
be added in the audit
log for future review.
Binary authorization is
integrated in Kubernetes Engine
and is now in beta.
To turn on, you first enable
the Binary Authorization API.
And then when you create or
update your Kubernetes Engine
clusters, you would turn the
Binary Authorization option on.
Then you will go ahead and
define your deployment rules
and Binary Authorization
policy either at the project
level, which would apply to
all clusters in the project,
or you can also define
granular cluster-level policy
override that
would define policy
for a particular cluster.
We also support
image whitelisting,
either using a repository,
a particular path,
a pattern of the
image name, a path,
or a particular set
of image digests.
As I mentioned, any violation
of the deployment policy
failed attempt would be
recorded in the audit log
and can be reviewed
later on in Stackdriver.
Now I will show you Binary
Authorization in action
by giving you a quick demo.
In this demo, we'll
show you two use cases.
One is enforcing deployment
of signed images.
Second is only deploy
whitelisted third-party images.
So let's start by
showing you how
signature verification works.
We have a pipeline here
that's built using CloudBees.
In the pipeline, there are two
attesting, or signing stages--
signing everything
that's built successfully
or signing something
that is built
from tagged or
production-ready code.
For the two signing
stages, we need
two corresponding
attesters created
in Binary Authorization.
So we have the build
attester and a tag attester.
Each of the attesters has
its own private signing key.
The public key is listed here.
But the customer
would be the one
managing the private signing
key that only the trusted stages
in the build pipeline have
access to that can produce
this signature or attestation.
So now let's switch
to the project
where the image will be
deployed and create clusters
with Binary
Authorization enabled.
So we'll have two clusters.
We'll have a dev cluster,
where we'll deploy anything,
as long as it's built
on a trusted pipeline.
I'll also have a
production cluster,
where I only want to deploy code
that are built from production
tagged code.
So let's go ahead and define
that in Binary Authorization
policy.
Policies are defined
in terms of attesters.
So the two attesters
that I created
would require the
build attester, i.e.,
anything with build
with security,
for the project
as a default rule.
With my production
cluster, I would
require both the build
attester, as well
as the tag attester, a.k.a.
having the tagged attestations
signifying that it's
built from tagged source code.
Now that I have
that defined, let's
go to our build pipeline
and start a build.
As you can see, that the build
runs through the attesting,
to build attestations stage, but
skipped the tagged attestations
stage because the
code is not tagged.
So the pipeline will not add
the tagged attestation to it.
So let's go into the
console and take a look
at what attestations are created
for the newly created image.
So we did a query.
And here, the image has
one new attestation.
Now let's deploy this
image to our dev cluster.
Take a look at the
work load data.
Yep, it was deployed successful
because dev cluster inherits
the default project
rule that only
requires build attestation.
Now lets try to
deploy that image
on the product
cluster, which requires
both a build attestation, as
well as the tagged attestation.
As expected, the
deployment failed
because the image does not
have the tagged attestations
since it was not built
from tagged code.
So let's go in and mark the code
for this image as production
ready and rebuild the image.
As you see, the build
pipeline skips ahead
and adds the tagged
attestation to the image
now that it's able to find
a tag on the source code.
And now let's try to deploy
the image to prod again.
All right, as
expected, it succeeds
because both
attestations are present.
Now let's take a look at how
to run third-party images
on infrastructure.
We'll use Nginx as an example.
So my security team has deemed
a particular version of Nginx
as trustworthy and want to
make sure that everybody only
deploys this version of Nginx
on the entire infrastructure.
But let's try to deploy it
before we modify our deployment
rule.
As you can see, the
deployment failed
because the images
are not built by me,
so it doesn't have the
necessary attestations.
Well, what we have to do is to
go into Binary Authorization
and add the image
to the white list.
The white list essentially
says that in addition
to any images that has
the right attestation,
the right signatures, also trust
these explicit list of images
that may not have the
right attestation,
in this case,
third party images.
Now that we've added it,
let's try to deploy it again.
Deployment was successful.
Well, what happens if I try to
do a different version of Nginx
that's different from what
my security team whitelisted
in the deployment policy?
That deployment fails because
it's a different digest.
Here is a link to Binary
Authorization website
for you to learn more.
And in addition to the
integrated deployment
policy enforcement provided
Binary Authorization
to Kubernetes Engine, what about
Kubernetes deployment that you
have on prem or elsewhere?
We believe that
deployed hand controls
is one of the key security
best practices for containers.
That is why we provided a open
source reference implementation
Kritis that will provide similar
enforcement flow for Kubernetes
deployment everywhere.
Kritis integrates with
Grafeas metadata API
that Juan just mentioned
earlier and provides enforcement
based on metadata that you
recorded in the Grafeas API.
It performs the enforcement
using Kubernetes admissions
controller.
And it's open source
built with the community.
It provides two parts.
It provides the enforcement,
deployment-time enforcement,
similar to Binary Authorization.
It also provides a signer
that connects metadata
to attestations.
So in this example,
the Kritis signer
would examine build or
vulnerability findings
published in any Grafeas
API and apply custom logics
to determine if the
findings are acceptable
to your organization.
If it is, it would
issue and attestation
that can be used to perform
deploy-time enforcement later
on.
Binary Authorization
is now in beta.
We just announced a
beta launch yesterday.
So welcome to come and try
and join our discussion group.
Let us know how you like it.
As a mission,
Binary Authorization
provides policy enforcement
for GKE at deploy time
both in terms of
signature verification,
as well as image whitelisting.
We provide project- and
cluster-level policies
via Grafeas and Kritis.
It integrates with GCR
Vulnerability Scanning
and Cloud Build.
We also support Breakglass
deployment, which I did not
mention in my presentation.
That is when if you have
a production emergency,
you are able to push through
deployments that do not
meet Binary Authorization policy
specifying a Breakglass flag.
And this incident
will be recorded,
and you can review this later.
This gives you the
flexibility to accommodate
any operational anomalies
in your deployment flow.
We also have partner support
from popular security tools,
such as Twistlock, as well
as popular CI/CD tools,
such as CloudBees and Jenkins.
So integration with your
existing CI/CD pipeline
should be very easy.
In addition to all that, we also
provide a open source reference
implementation that you can use
for your Kubernetes deployment
outside of GKE.
Thank you.
So what's next, Maya?
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Thanks, Sandra.
So you should
definitely check out
Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanning
and Binary Authorization.
There's lots of
other things you can
do to protect your
containers as well.
There's a lot of
guidance you can follow.
So we've tried to
break this down by how
mature your deployment is.
First you have to
set up a cluster.
You're going to want
some basic functionality
to provide user management
and network segmentation.
These include how you're
going to access kubectl,
how you prevent
access to your users
using RBAC, how you restrict
intra-cluster traffic
with a network policy,
how you architect your app
and segment your cluster
using namespaces,
and how you boot strap
trust for your cluster CA.
Now that you're up
and running, you're
going to want to maintain
some basic security hygiene.
This is about ensuring that
you're using containers
to really leverage
their security benefits.
This includes keeping Kubernetes
in your OS packages, images,
et cetera updated
and patched, using
a minimal OS for
a smaller surface
attack, like
Container-optimized OS,
or COS on Kubernetes engine,
using minimum IAM rules
for least privilege,
private IP addresses
to limit network
connectivity of your cluster,
monitoring access
with audit logging,
and ensuring that only the
binaries that you build
are deployed.
That's Binary Authorization.
Once that's done,
prevent known attacks.
These are common
misconfigurations in Kubernetes
or known vulnerabilities that
could affect your cluster.
These include disabling
the Kubernetes dashboard
because it has
privileged access,
disabling the default
service account token,
protecting node metadata as
it may grant broader access
than needed, and
scanning your images
for known vulnerabilities,
for example
using Container
Registry Vulnerability
Scanning, and lastly,
limiting the impact
of a potential compromise.
This more traditional
hardening and fine tuning
of your environment includes
setting a Pod Security
Policy to limit what's
deployed in your environment,
protecting your secrets,
sandboxing certain highly risky
workloads, limiting
the identity that pods
use to authenticate
to other services,
and using a service mesh
to enforce strong network
protection between
your services.
So there's a lot here.
We'll put a link
up at the end where
you can find out more
about hardening advice
for Kubernetes.
But don't despair.
There's a lot going on
in the container security
space and a lot you can do to
help protect your containers.
And so those are the two items
we really covered today, right?
Binary Authorization
and Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanning are
just one piece of a broader
container security story.
So in addition to what
we just covered today,
why would you consider
Kubernetes Engine
over running Kubernetes
yourself, from a purely
security point of view?
Well, first of all,
Kubernetes Engine
provides some common security
best practices by default.
There are more things
being built in and turned
on by default which you
just kind of benefit from,
which you don't have
to manage yourself.
There's always going
to be applicable
hardening you have to do for
your specific application.
Next, a lot of these new
defaults and security
patches automatically and
easily end up in your deployment
because Kubernetes patches
you to the latest master
version automatically.
And you can also enable Node
Auto Upgrade to get the latest
version running on your nodes.
We talked about
containers enabling
a simpler patch management
system for your environment.
That's not really helpful
if you're not also
patching Kubernetes.
So use something like
Node Auto Upgrade
to make that even
easier on yourself.
And lastly, it works
with the rest of GCP.
You can use IAM, audit logging,
VPCs, and other products
that you're already familiar
with as part of your Kubernetes
deployment.
And Binary Authorization,
Container Registry
Vulnerability Scanning,
they all work together
as part of a broader
picture you can use on GCP.
So if you want to learn more,
there's a couple links things
here, our general
container security overview
and then the deep dives
on the two products
that we talked about today.
And please stay
tuned for a live Q&A.
We'll be back in
less than a minute.
Thanks.
JUAN SEBASTIAN OVIEDO:
Welcome back, everyone.
Now let's go over some
of your questions.
First question that
we got was, how
do I use Grafeas with Kritis?
SANDRA GUO: I'll take that one.
So Grafeas provides an open
source metadata format and API
for users to conveniently
store and retrieve metadata
associated with containers.
Kritis provides the enforcement
piece of that story.
So you can imagine
that you would
use Grafeas to store metadata,
such as vulnerability findings
or verifiable build
record that describes
how your containers
are built. And then you
can use Kritis to
define how you want
to enforce deployment using
those information stored
in Grafeas.
As we mentioned earlier, you can
have a locally hosted Grafeas
instance, or you can have
a Grafeas implementation
as hosted by GCP, which is
the container analysis API.
Kritis or Binary
Authorization works
with both implementations.
With Kritis, we provide
a open source signer
that you can define what is
acceptable in a vulnerability
finding or in a verifiable build
record that you would generate
attestation only if an image has
the recommended build record,
as well as vulnerability
levels, which
can be then enforced and
deployed [INAUDIBLE]..
So in short, Grafeas
provide the metadata piece
that you can insert and
retrieve and examine metadata.
Kritis provide the
deploy-time enforcement piece.
And they do work together.
JUAN SEBASTIAN OVIEDO: Awesome.
Awesome.
Our next question is, why use
a central metadata repository?
And why not put this data with
the container using labels?
SANDRA GUO: The
first order for that
is because containers
are immutable,
and labels are considered
part of a container image.
So when a label change, the
identifier of a container
would also change,
which is the digest.
To digest the open container
is content addressable.
So this doesn't
really work well when
you want to attach mutable
metadata, such as image
findings, vulnerability
findings, or test results
that are generated after
a container is built.
That is why we choose
to keep the metadata
outside of the image.
It will also decouple it from
the image repository and easier
to integrate with
different systems
that you may have in
your CI/CD workflow.
Our next question's
for you, Juan.
Does vulnerability
scanning cover CentOS?
JUAN SEBASTIAN OVIEDO:
Currently, it doesn't cover it.
But it's something that
we're actively working on.
And we'll release support for
both CentOS and Red Hat soon.
We'll share more details
in the near future.
But it's one of the top
requests that we've received,
and we're actively
working on support
for those two distributions.
Next question, for Sandra,
how should I manage the keys
for my attestation authorities?
SANDRA GUO: Yep.
So you would manage
the keys yourself.
We currently don't have a key
management solution integrated
with Binary Authorization.
So if you have an attester
that is doing the signing,
that attester would have access
to the private signing key.
And the public key
will be uploaded
into Binary
Authorization policy so
that we can use the public
key to verify the signature
as the image gets deployed.
But for now you'll be the one
managing the private signing
keys yourself.
Next one, what
partners can I use
with vulnerability scanning?
JUAN SEBASTIAN OVIEDO:
So currently, they're
not directly exposed in the
GCR UI that I showed you.
But there's work ongoing in the
cloud security command center.
And there are
integrations happening
from different partners,
including Twistlock,
for example.
And basically in
the CSCC you'll be
able to access the
vulnerability findings
from different providers.
One provider is DCR
Vulnerability Scanning.
The other providers,
for example, the ones
that I mentioned before.
And you'll be able to
see a full list of them.
You'll be able to organize
this data in one location.
And it's also aggregated
across projects.
So it's a great
tool, and I highly
recommend you guys look into it.
SANDRA GUO: How can I find
out if the vulnerabilities
discovered by GCR
Vulnerability Scanning
apply to any of my
running environments?
It's a really good question.
JUAN SEBASTIAN OVIEDO:
Great question, Sandra.
And that's a question that
we've heard consistently
as part of our conversations
with customers.
And it's something that we're
also actively working on.
We understand that
there's a lot of value
in finding the vulnerabilities.
But then the key
impact is knowing
are these vulnerabilities in
any of my running environments?
And that's why we're actively
working on any deployment
history to
vulnerability scanning.
And we'll also have more
details on that soon,
but it's something that
we're actively working on.
SANDRA GUO: All
right, thank you.
Stay tuned for the
next session, CE Chat,
Building Startup Light
Nighter with GCP.
Thank you.
JUAN SEBASTIAN
OVIEDO: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]